[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that makes a lot more sense
when did you get my wallet it was out
here this entire time i'm a magician
there's money in here did the show start
agents
get out of here learn about petty theft
on breakthrough stole my wallet if there
is a brand that i want new rockstars
fans to know is my brand of stealing
from people i usually make that joke all
the time
any time we're talking about the blip
i'm like oh i would have stole
everything i would imagine that freaking
like half thousands are open like the
housing market is 50 but i'm gonna steal
your home yeah you figure it out but
like literally half the store is empty
no one is worried about how this just
happened
my wallet was in my pocket
a minute ago
suddenly she's going through it back to
the break room i'm the thief my name's
jessica clements
nerdy news to you guys today coming up
we have uh spider-man 4 talks i put up
five
uh you know we were talking about that
thor that's dropping today today as
early as like 5 p.m in some places today
um
and we can say that because we just got
100
and then we'll get to cursing in our
introductions uh we also have daredevils
coming back for more i think we've been
hearing these rumors we need to talk
about it you kick his ass
i said stay down daredevil
uh whatever stick around and find out we
have the uh redemption swear jar as you
know and as soon as we reach 100 like we
do right now we're going to start
cursing so let's start with philip
molina hi uh each of us what's happening
yeah go ahead and cruise each of us
anymore okay great uh uh i am here and i
know
uh
not even a uh corn of [ __ ] of what we're
talking about uh do you say i'm ready
a corner of [ __ ] it's the smallest
possible piece of matter that can exist
in [ __ ]
um
it's the atom of [ __ ] um a kernel i
learned something new today uh
because uh uh they just called me up and
said hey can you be in this and i'm like
yes i will always say yes but i have no
idea what we're talking about
i'm sure i'll be able to contribute it's
happening live
with you perfect and erica hey hey
america wussuf [ __ ] it we'll do it live
here we are at jar live internet
television i wish that's how the
original clip was of a bill of right
[ __ ] it we'll do a live stream
i am the complete opposite of bill
o'reilly in several ways that is one of
the ways yesterday you convinced me of a
tattoo on your back
that bill o'reilly also absolutely has
that
blaming saddle's tattoo i was fully
convinced for about half a second
really impressed with that work i'm a
good communicator
also someone tweeted me and was like
please only introduce koi with that
hostility so
it's your turn
[ __ ]
uh i have been up since uh 4 15 this
morning i introduced all of the thors
for marvel and nerdist the el capitan we
did the entire marathon i was just in
thor for nine hours and i can say
that it was such a cool day to like hear
those like some of the easter eggs and
discover things again and to see like
the the 616 written on the first talk of
multiverse back in 2013 with dark world
and to see where we are now just to
relive those moments and then to have
love and thunder with a brand new
audience when i've seen it to wait for
those moments and i'm so excited for all
of you to get to experience it it's been
a great day and i'm on hour 14. those
groups of people got to see eleven
thunder like just right at the end of it
i left 30 minutes of it left so i saw
the first hour and a half with them came
here those people started watching at
l.a that's why i got up at 5 00 a.m
because we started at six
and it's been going yeah so yeah we our
our 11 thunder dropped at one you might
need my coffee he's clearly full of
cocaine
i'm on the left and the thunder
thinking of love and thunder
uh today's biggest nerd news is that
both charlie cox and vincent d'onofrio
are coming back to the mcu the hollywood
reporter is reporting that both
daredevil and kingpin will be part of
the upcoming echo series on disney plus
we're going to come back to this soon
you guys we're going to come back to
this soon um we just need you to drop
any questions you might have in the chat
about it anything you want us to like
talk about want us to uh expand unbox
let us know just letting you know
because headlines happens first and then
we get into the meeting
and then we get into the meeting take
two let's do it
and then we get into let's go
fingering my straw
um stranger things creator man ross
duffer the duffer brothers recently sat
down with collider's editor-in-chief
steve
weintraub i probably pronounce it wrong
sorry steve to discuss the work that
went into season four including some
characters whose lives were spared said
matt in terms of who makes it who lives
or who dies i think there was a version
where dimitri aka enzo didn't make it
do we
care if enzo would have lived or died
enzo is the uh
the uh the friend that helps not the
pilot right john not the pilot
yeah the prison guard sounds like no no
one would care because the name is not
exactly enough for us to invest too much
as a reminder who the character is
that's the guy you can't remember do you
care about the guy you can't remember
the
who
exactly but like i didn't even
[Applause]
um yeah should have killed i think
the internet feels maybe a similar way
it should have just killed me i don't i
like him he's the only russian character
in film and tv that i actually like no i
meant kill one of the kids oh yeah i
don't mind [ __ ] dancing
sorry no more sweaters
[Laughter]
if we reach 200 in the swear jar he'll
get that weird tattoo what a white woman
at that so that's what happened we were
talking about places
no no no no no there's no way to make
this make sense yeah don't even try it
one video would be like what happened i
heard blazing saddles butt tattoo where
the white women at
those are never coming together
the senior film reporter at collider
jeff snyder who uh wrote a piece that
wrote a piece called this date of sony
for the angler yesterday some
interesting details all spider-man plans
are tentative as tom holland is not
officially signed on for any future
movies at all
he's got retiring yeah
oh my god we got a good run we did
honestly um i think i thought we i
thought that was known maybe yeah it
wasn't uh i don't know i thought
sony isn't involved in disney plus
animated spider-man uh freshman year
show as its spider-man rights are
limited to live-action and animated
films do we think that marvel would ever
do a live-action tom holland spider-man
disney plush show
i think it'd be an interesting
conversation about budget and like mcu
restrictions because i do think you want
to have the certain like the the shows
we've had so far aren't shows we've
really seen in the other medium right
like we saw hawkeye but that's a lower
budget take on the character we've had
moonlight new loki one division is kind
of the newest
loki kind of some almost did pull off a
movie level thing right it's a movie
level character exploring an entire new
world yeah but that character's power
set is so uh exposition like it's
dialogue based mischief is so verbal
i don't know he could do some mischief
that's physical too they already did the
short so i think you might as well just
give him the show um even if i think
it'd also be cute to do like an animated
show with tom hall and voicing that
that's cute here's my pitch live action
disney plus show uh we only know a
version of spiderman in the mcu who's
like hey i'm your friendly neighborhood
goes to space and saves the universe you
know it's like what if we actually had
to deal with you know like
not even kingpin right like a lower
level kind of issue of something where
he's trying to solve something uh
especially now when nobody knows who he
is right so he has no help he can't
guess he's in the costumes he's having
an iron spider suit he's very much like
70s exactly he's rebooting to his
original originals
you know we skipped spider-man 1 in a
sense with his character right he
already existed and was doing his thing
and he immediately is like joining
avengers and whatnot so let's go back
and play a neighborhood story over the
course of nine episodes what i love
about the six movie origin is that we
did finally at
number six get to number one so i think
what the best thing they could do is to
differentiate themselves from either
andrew or toby is to take a long-form
time and let him be in college let him
meet gwen stacy let him yeah you know go
to that world jessica jones style pacing
of like there's like a case essentially
she's trying to figure out yeah and the
crime stuff of the 70s was solid and i
think that's what we're going to be
looking at is the 70s and 80s spider-man
was that jeremy to senior art was that
like ross andrew and that was the
day-to-day spider-man life and we've
never i mean even for sam raimi i don't
think we've ever really gotten that i'm
gonna stop youtube because i think you
guys are already airing out your
screenplays
kevin feige does weigh in and offer
notes on sony's marvel movies that don't
feature spider-man kevin feige actually
had to warn sony about including
multiversal themes in its spider-man
spin-off projects it might not be morbid
time in the mcu
that's what he said he said it himself
he said it might not be fine
just yet baby uh
do you think he does that like
graduating college or high school he
just turns
out
i think he like pulls on it really hard
and he goes
and the new one like spins into place
when things are green lit new hat he's
just at the ready
green lid
the amount of hats he has is
too much so i want like one of my goals
is to have each of his hats and have a
closet big enough for like it's an
actual goal of mine do you have the
foggy collection of hats get better
goals
it's not the only goal it's a goal i
know i know
i don't know because that implies the
house big enough for the closet that
implies the connection to have those
hats oh bad being bad with money
oh i don't want to buy the hats i want
to be giving heal the hats and she will
find a way
he's like i had a hat on my head a
second ago i sit on top and then the
blitz [ __ ] steal someone's house big
enough for a closet for all those hats
now you got me that's where we're at
just gone okay nine episode run where
peter parker is hiding in kevin feige's
closet trying to steal his deadpool's
in an interview with empire spoiler
special podcast dr strange and the
multiverse and madness producer richie
palmer talked about the untold story
behind earth 838 and how the tony stark
of that world plays into everything he
says but this is a world where ultron
seemed to work that uh worked the way
tony stark intended him to work in age
of ultron a suit of armor around the
world tony was trying to get the
avengers to retire in age of ultron so
imagine that this is what wanda wanted
you know this is what uh around that
time this is a world where tony cracked
ultron and it worked and he went hey
whoever wants to retire can go home can
interesting
louise interesting so that would make
sense obviously the the like ultron bots
uh yeah they were so formed and like
functioning yeah yeah so what what would
the difference be like it was voiced by
michael scott instead of
scott you mean uh james spader no i'm
saying we got james spader oh they get
michael yeah
yeah they're just gonna
what was the issue with ultron right
like ultimately why didn't it work
because he self-activated and saw that
humanity was worth saving by connecting
to the internet so he saw all over trump
so is it just like a version that never
got wi-fi like is that the difference he
was only on bluetooth and ethernet
i imagine what it was was in that world
they had advanced enough where they
could compensate for what the internet
showed him like maybe he saw what
humanity and accomplished to stop from
like where we are now like theoretically
as an optimist i hope in 20 years we're
at a better place
you know it wouldn't take much for the
internet that we're at to have been a
curated internet right it started as a
military project but then also i mean
for stretch there america online
actually had a monopoly based on what we
consumed as the internet there is a
version where the internet is not a um
there's no 4chan right right there's no
you know there's no truth
yeah okay
too
okay now it is time for our discussion
what you guys came for the thumbnail so
charlie cox vincent and offery are
returning for the marvel series echo
sources say echo will include a plot
line in which daredevil whose alter ego
is the blind attorney matt murdock is
searching out i just thought you thought
his name was the blind attorney i'll
tell you blind determination
i can't see
uh his former ally who is daredevil
searching for clearly okay you guys
we've been seeing these rumors online
jessica jones but this is a rumor and
this is a new show and what we do here
is we get facts to you and if we think
it's
anytime we do bring something up that's
like literally on the fence we say it's
a rumor so i'm saying right now that it
is a rumor that jessica jones will
appear in this we don't know for sure
yet so we're trying to figure out who
could be the other ally that's not just
no way it'll be jessica jones she don't
think no she's way too sexy for this
world no this like world is this world
like tristan
i say this for an angel like a crying
over a tombstone too sexy for this world
i'd be like oh my god someone take this
man away
he's not wrong
i can't stand up right now
um no what i mean is that okay i didn't
love the kingpin portrayal uh in hawkeye
it was like a goofball it reminded me of
like jingle all the way or something
where it's like a fun movie in a uh fao
shorts fight scene or whatever
okay that world and jessica jones
getting slammed repeatedly uh yeah by
luke cage open the show those like
worlds right now not feeling like the
same word not very congruent yeah yeah
that's true i would like jessica jones
because jessica jones is so like edgy
and dark i feel like echo has a lot of
darkness clearly in her and she's kind
of like on the run and so if they need
to find someone he's going to sort find
jessica jones the photographer not
jessica jones
like the private detective yeah yeah the
private detective and that that would
lead to it but i also i'm still i want
it to be uh jennifer walters
free oh like he knows her as an attorney
yeah and then they work together yeah
and i want to praise the friend
so i want her to be just jessica or
jessica so many jessica's so many j's i
wanted to be jennifer walters and then
he shows up and it's maybe her ass
i mean that's like that spits the world
i'm talking about more where it's like
oh oh and then high choices yeah
but what what do we know about um is it
karen page uh and uh foggy bottom nelson
like like where
could he just be looking yeah
i don't know if they're big enough for
like whatever this log line sounds like
it is like i don't know if they'd list
that as like a goal of the show whereas
like we the problem with the the
she-hulk timeline is she looks next and
echoes not till next year so i don't
know if they'd be like having daredevil
search for someone who we just had a
show of whereas we did see that image of
of you know mike holter and jessica
jones like hanging out and then he's
like oh my god and then his caption was
also like big thing come in soon and tag
marvel so that to me like i i usually
don't like rumors but if cast is like
i i'm at least interested so i think it
could be a jessica jones you think it
can be like
says echo follows maya lopez as her life
in new york as a gang leader catches up
with her and she returns to her hometown
to reconnect with her native american
roots so that's the storyline we're
getting in the show
storyline or storyline from the comics
in the show are kind of different uh
yeah the joke of saturn i don't remember
i read a little bit of it and i was like
oh it's not i think they're trying to
make it there's some shows for them to
you though i think they're like yeah
these characters are from the comics but
we really want these to be for the
television right so i think that's what
we're getting here and it worked for
kamala khan like yeah i'm digging kamala
khan's new take and it's very different
100
it feels a little bit like there's
something tribal to the echo story and
there's like like with the hand and
everything there there were elements of
like getting into a secret culture
within a culture
maybe he's like trying to find someone
that
connects their two worlds like also what
was the name of the um
was it i was gonna say madame butterfly
or something
no no no no no uh no the um the like
head of the like of one of the gang
families the older the older ones oh an
older woman the older woman i don't
remember the i don't know
yeah either way like someone who like
knows about all of the different uh
infrastructures that have like kind of a
sub genre so in the show this is us
going back to hawkeye really quick for
um
for um for echo so she her she basically
is betrayed she realized that like her
dad died at the hands of everyone that
she trusted so she's on the run correct
so
maybe she's not tied to anyone i i only
say this because i'm like i think madame
gao would be like i'm not involved with
her she's not in new york yeah she ran
somewhere else yeah so it's like if
she's on the run is it just wilson fisk
following after her does she what does
she have that wilson fisk really needs
does that make sense also
uh
yeah it's revenge
she's shy
wouldn't he be also going for like um
okay bishop too in this i guess in this
instance i mean long term theoretically
but
in the narrative
what about
punisher
so that's the big like ally i was
thinking like because you know john
bernthal coming back is the pipe dream
because like punisher is a character
that is like kind of awkward right now
in time
but actually in there right does kind of
work and also like you could do so many
story lines like um you know the movie
witness
uh it's a harrison ford and like there's
a witness to a murder whatever and they
end up in dutch pennsylvania
yeah like these like characters that
need to go somewhere where like people
go to disappear and then the characters
that know how to pierce that veil and
kind of get in there it feels like
punisher would be one where yeah i know
how to get in and he knows the
underbelly and he can navigate it
differently than daredevil
maybe
maybe i'm in the wrong spot because he
uh he was on court in daredevil and then
he went off and everyone was like oh
he's guilty the punisher yeah but then
he had a season two where he's you know
he's doing his thing yeah yeah and in
the comics right now he's like leading
the hand which is interesting like in
the comics he
swore an allegiance to kill as many bad
people as he could so he actually got
like powers from the hand and he's
leading a clan of hand and he's like
they're their big beast like the the
beast of the undead is the punisher and
for the cost of bringing his wife back
so his wife's like undead and like
living as a hand member and he's murking
fools it's great good run beautiful
merkin merkin fools merkin you know what
i'm talking about
and his
wife oh my god
do we think that matt murdock might be
the antagonist of this series if not
matt murdock who do we think could it be
a new supporting character an old
supporting character i wha what what
generates a question of him being an
antagonist well because my gut says no
but is there a reason
oh so just like matt murdock not
daredevil
maybe like true but although he's the
defense attorney right
but he's also just like i guess his
mission is always like i'm here to
protect
i'm here to protect my hell's kitchen
yeah hell's kitchen this is my house and
he's like
they leave the plastic charlie box
i swear i can't i can't i can't i'm
sorry it's me the blind attorney
thank you for reiterating that that it
could be matt murdock or daredevil i
could see matt murdock being the
antagonist and daredevil trying to clear
up his name like he usually has to
um but it's also like yeah he's still
the law at the end of the day and echoes
on the run for being a part of a big
crime i feel like that's gonna be a
subplot of she-hulk though i feel like
matt murdock being on the other side of
a court case and i do think shield is
going to be you haven't been here a bit
but my big theory is dodc is going to be
uh the the big thing that kind of brings
back the civil war registration act sure
sure and shield might be the first like
superhero attorney that defends
superheroes so maybe matt has to maybe
go against his own kind like he has to
introduce him i like the idea of them
picking up the threat of like so where's
the current state of the government
especially without thunderbolt ross on
the rp like how are they gonna gonna
make that because the thunderbolts being
like
someone that bait and switches is a
great setup for x-men not being trusted
and all those things can lead from her
story somebody i just missed them out of
the corner of my eye so somebody was
like oh it's obvious it's elektra and
it's like there's something there with
like elektra to echo and like i don't
know that would be a cool like badass
pairing i guess my biggest question at
the end of this is what shows aren't
involved in echo and shield
daredevil because we they just because
they're a part of the law it's like
that's such an umbrella
guys disney owns everything it's
possible it's possible do you think this
will i don't know i don't think it's
going to be too many cameos in um echo
but do we think it'll be like at least
just like one two yeah to the netflix to
the net or the street level netflix it
feels like it's a catch-all for that
right where it's kind of like who did we
forget to give a show to i think it's
bringing in netflix i think it's a way
to like kind of scoop out and call it a
new character so you're not confusing so
then who so so jessica jones who else
has not does not have a plan to get
brought in yet from netflix
luke cage would be good i really want
the punisher and i can't wait till the
punishment i think the way you do it is
have a show that's a new ip and that way
you don't confuse people with the name
recognition and then once they're back
in this way then you can start daredevil
season four how about we scrap all day
these ideas and just do iron fist again
i think yeah that's yeah that's what
everybody wants right everybody's right
there
yeah
i'm still writing spider-man and you're
you keep ryan spider-man and you also
keep writing spider-man
god
god bless spiderman
every one of us you guys thank you for
joining our little discussion but feel
free to keep asking us questions that we
will put in the that we will answer um
kenny c says wouldn't it be great if mcu
professor x is one of them uh is one to
help wanda heal i would smack him upside
that head
i would smack him upside that head uh
the storm virgil says the soldier boy's
dna was put in stormfront no you can't
call it because daschle our cameraman
already called me oh i don't think it
was put in her i think i think you think
it was no because i don't think you need
to be on the show tomorrow do you
remember that they were
she had a different name yes and they
were looking up liberty yeah but i think
she's aware i don't think soulja boy is
aware that his firm was mixed with her i
don't think he's aware that she's a nazi
but i think he knows oh he knows
i think oh yeah i don't know if he cares
but like i i definitely think that
that's a baby that came out natural oh
my god oh well natural for her he i feel
like didn't know anything because she
was also involved with the lab in season
that's true you guys i'm sorry real
quick i just want to go back real quick
to the kenny c's thing about professor x
being the one that's helping want to
heal the uh what is really cool about
that is professor x has done that for
like jean grey and like that's a
character that we all have so much
emotional investment in so it's like
he's going to try to bring her back from
her dark phoenix story we don't care
about the dark phoenix story in in the
mcu but wanda being a character that
needs to be like redeemed and like her
getting this special uh new character to
come into professor x and getting to you
know try to fix her and find her again
we took the time we should have with the
phoenix exactly right we actually have
the phoenix talk at claremont right now
not like it's a movie so like we've
earned this slogan
you can retroactively fix a lot of the
multiverse and madness problems like you
can make you unscrew
i mean obviously
eyes undilate
no but like you can make those uh
was that his
chair yeah
but like the basically those those
little beats in the multiverse that they
skipped over for going dark you could do
in reverse you could see her coming back
to the light and yeah have the scenes
play out in her memory and yeah yeah you
can still care i just don't want
professor x helping her um also sorry
chrissy christie said i heard sperm and
nazis what is happening
to the boys the weirdest love triangle
i've seen in a while
i don't want to be involved where the
white girls at sperm and nazi
where everyone wins
we also have our new oh that doesn't say
my name
hi
uh your latest uh obsession uh we drop
our latest obsession lines uh constantly
what we do is we do koi do you know what
the latest obsession is the first time
really this section okay so latest
obsession is our uh like new rockstars
thing that we're currently obsessed with
we make a shirt to celebrate that thing
cool but we release them as like limited
editions we number the caller and
everything and it's a little piece of
like the only thing we keep is maybe the
artwork or whatever but like that
limited run is done and you never see it
again until uh black friday sometimes uh
but otherwise never see it again
but the thor one right now is uh worthy
of love
and it's super it's like synthwave retro
very funky we actually have a paired one
where it's like a jane one either way if
you go to uh newrockstarsmerch.com
you'll see it my favorite part of our
latest obsession uh stuff koi if you
ever want to get a message to eric i
know that you've been trying
if you buy yeah yeah uh if you buy one
of these shirts you get a little option
to put in like a shout out and then on
inside marvel those shout outs run on
the bottom of the screen and if you have
a challenge to him or something you want
to you know like go break 1v1
yeah yeah
i saw it in the chat too uh uh he can
put it there and then he has to
acknowledge it and then he has to put a
tattoo on eric or who's his back this is
uh whatever it is
so definitely make sure to check out uh
our latest obsession there but also just
in general all of our thor stuff we're
gonna drop some more thor merch soon but
the current run is actually just very
fun already the gore the god butcher
thing have you you saw it because you
saw the poster yeah yeah that's one of
my favorite pieces like we've ever made
it's just like this sick like metal
poster of like a taurine band called
like god butcher yes it's just like all
the different planets that they're gonna
go kill the gods and then
so it's like it's different than a
normal poster it's like this by this
yeah it's based on the torso i wish i
had
yeah yeah
and it's got a sword going through thor
guys you guys don't know what it's time
for what is it
uh optional good times
optional okay
mandatory fun all right that sounds way
better play that graphic
okay and then in honor of our fallen
comrade you play that graphic one more
again
all right all right all right because
you guys are mocking me i'm going to
make this harder okay so uh thor 11
thunder does come out tonight and uh
none of us are worthy to lift this uh i
think it's popcorn filled uh uh mjolnir
reforged up here uh but
every time i try to lift it i just
opened
you unforged it ah
reforged your hand's part of it now
um all right so uh here's the thing can
i say something really quick about this
please you guys this is the thor um
the more worthy she's worthy look at
that
this is not an ad but these are
available opening today at any amc um
for thor 11 thunder they started selling
them right as doors opened this morning
so if you saw minions you could have saw
this uh but also they are selling out
very quickly when i got there they only
had six left so and i went at like noon
so our goal is going to be to not lift
that part and only lift this far we'll
see how that works out um but you ever
wonder like what it would take for you
to be worthy and i'm sure we've all
measured like okay how worthy because
honestly thor parties
right
cap was worthy but thor parties a lot
he can and like hella didn't technically
lift it but odin has like people have
done some bad stuff so i feel like
there's actually a line that is you
could draw and that's so currently i
decided none of you are worthy i'm not
worthy either but
we discovered uh time travel as possible
through through miss marvel a new a new
form of time travel so we can go back
and rewrite history and adjust it okay
so i want you guys to tell a story
to our audience here and it's the one
thing that if you go back and change
this this is your best bet on we've gone
and we changed it and now you will be
worthy
so
one story can be embarrassing or it can
be a a mistake that you committed and
you're just gonna let it out you haven't
told anybody this is part of the shame
letting go of the shame is also a big
part of being worthy
who's ready to get something out there
swollen chest
swollen [ __ ] i'm gonna look i'm looking
at koi yeah
it's all that thor
i'm trying to think of one too it's hard
like what's what's what's the worst
thing ever done on live tv
yeah this is not tv
some people are watching on a roku yeah
okay
see embarrassing or shameful
[Music]
do you have any of course you want to go
first
no i'm not going to go first but i'll go
last but i'll buy you guys time but what
i'll give to the audience is the
audience you all know me you know i make
a living i tell embarrassing stories on
the internet i've got a number of them
so i'll let you guys uh dawson if you
can create a poll
i've got some categories of the kind
let's see you can find the story about
drunkenness
self-discovery
the fires
don't open that door
uh and he's he's my tutor
i don't know if we can do five so you
can cut one of them is fine but uh if
the audience can pick from those uh in
the poll i will go ahead and try to be
worthy after it i can try and be worthy
here ah no maybe not me first i forgot
my mom watches this
but that's the thing we're all
struggling tell her i have stories tell
her like
i said i said it wasn't me
you're about to admit something you've
been waiting
it sounds like it's the one that needs
something
yeah so when i was a younger girl a
younger gal and this is younger when i
know some of you guys in the chat are
way too young you didn't recognize like
what happened when we first had ipods
and iphones like the first chunky like
full black iphone that was like this big
so i had it and itunes was like a weird
mystery
and we didn't really know how to use
itunes then itunes doesn't even exist
now and um i had a boyfriend um
once upon a time i had a boyfriend and
um
sometimes you get little bored you know
and sometimes just send a butt pikachu
to your boyfriend right mom i'm so sorry
oh my gosh
and uh your mom texts you and she's like
jessica
someone's messages are coming through on
my phone and i go no you're just being
crazy and then i keep continuing to send
these
and um she goes no it's just it's just
weird it's just crazy literally that's
when i was like oh my god we're on the
shared itunes account so all my
imessages ever since i got my first
iphone went to my mom's phone as well
and she never text she just like to play
the apps how did you convince her it
wasn't you i just said that's crazy it
must be i wi-fi because of the bluetooth
because people are sending it it's going
to you and she was like okay and then
since that i remember i took itunes off
her phone i was like you got to make
your own account so you got to make your
own account yeah make your own account
and um i would
be such a liar if i said that that
wasn't my last time that that happened
in my life i did it to a work computer
too
here
you
you said that was my butt
oh that's your butt i mean obviously
yeah everybody knows
that oh that is my boy how did you tell
your mom that that wasn't your she said
no one has seen your butt more times
than your mother not a grown woman but
she saw my baby she saw what it could
become yeah she said yeah she said
theoretically this is worthy yeah this
looks like everybody's
i literally was just like sorry mom not
really good at electronics i was just
like oh wi-fi it must have air dropped
on to yourself
you
yeah all right
give it give it a shot okay can you
separate what if i'm not worthy after
saying that embarrassing thing you gotta
admit more oh mom i'm sorry with my butt
also oh i'm sorry to the it team at my
last job
[Music]
this story has happened even more times
than you just admitted to and that's why
you couldn't lift it
that is a yes
your turn
all right so i guess mine also involves
computers that were not only mine
uh when i was a younger lad also in the
itunes era uh some of you guys may
remember the
uh
proliferation of illegally streaming and
downloading not us yeah
i used one called aries is the one i
used to use not many people i kind of
remember that yeah it was just in the
frame it was another one and you know
i'm a young lad i'm in my teens and i'm
starting to discover
boobies on the internet so
i get to i think i'm streaming things
you know watch them keep it moving
nothing's sticking on the computer so i
thought uh i was wrong it was
constantly
saving more than just cookies and cachet
these were like full videos
storing onto the family computer in the
basement like i got real good in the
basement i got because the positioning
of our family computer if you come down
the stairs gives you a couple seconds
you you can hear oh my ears became like
bat like oh it was better than morbius's
sonar
so
anytime
glad you're less worthy
uh so
i i'm i'm doing my thing and i'm
listening out for stairs
steps coming downstairs and the computer
i go to log on after school one day i'm
like oh what are we going to download
today and the computer just was like
nope we're done we're full of viruses
and just you know windows but you
remember how windows would pop up and
just freeze and just like this is what
you're looking at this is what you're
looking for
and i couldn't turn it off i couldn't
you just got you got solitaire but porn
yes like finish the game oh you remember
single one of us had a version of that
exact story i did it because i was a
good baby no you were the one making
this
sending
[Laughter]
so my parents were like
who did this
love your face
i don't know
did computers just fail sometimes yeah
siblings yeah yeah okay so i had a
little brother who was like way too
young
oh my god
uh try having that same story and be
like this weird virus is maybe bisexual
we are so crazy what's happening weird
how it does that because the vpns and
the wi-fi yeah you know you should have
unplugged the router it's coming from
multiple try lift this down all right
all right let's go
i do see some separation points here
yeah okay let me try to start it oh yeah
this is going to smack me
he gave it a hole
[Laughter]
don't put your mouth in this popcorn
you guys just forgot existed today
it is not a harmonica i can hear the
basement
don't listen too close you hear the
dialogue
yeah
no that's a boy squealing
okay okay
so i'm not gonna go with anything hey
don't gift this moment right now i'm
jessica doing this
[Laughter]
okay so i don't have any uh in that
direction i'm sure i do but i'm gonna go
with the one i first thought of and that
is uh i i started the entrepreneur they
call it entrepreneurship now but like
hustle young uh i would go into lunch
and i'd have lunch but i'd go to like i
made sure to make a lot of friends for
the point of profit and that's probably
not so wholesome so like i pride myself
on me and something to talk to everybody
so i played football one year i
cheerlead one year i'm a nerd so i like
knew every table so i go to you tell me
like hey i forgot my lunch and i got
like 50 cents and i would collect
all of this money and then i'd go buy
comics
and then i'd start my comic collection
but then i get doubles the comic flip
those for car parts flip the car parts
on ebay so basically i turned like
little bits of 50 cents into how i
eventually moved to la so i would like i
kind of crowdfunded my my hustle
starting from like fourth grade up until
now but i also when i got jobs i'd use
that same hustle where like i'd work at
a movie theater and there'd be like a
really long line for like lord of the
rings let's say theoretically and there
was no reserve seats yet so it'd be like
well we want to go to the front line 20
bucks and i'd like bring people to like
upstairs through the other entrance and
bring them in or like oh you're there's
no refills but i got this cup for the
employee and like so i just like flipped
whatever job plus the other money and
then eventually made a money move to l.a
so you asked me for gas money to come
here that did you need to experiment
number 20. i need that damn scorpio
you know when you watch like a life hack
or whatever and it's like step one find
a ball step two and step three is like
have an amazing thing created he somehow
skipped over real quick he's like i
would have uh comic books i'd flip them
for car parts
i'd build a ferrari
you can't flip a comic book so like
i grew up in lowell so there was a comic
store that was also a skate shop also a
pokemon shop so if you get like some
comics that are worth a little bit more
some of the people that like sold car
parts on the street would want those
comics because they were looking for
them so i'd often buy since i knew
comics i'd buy two of an issue i thought
be collectible so i'd keep one let it
rise in value trade it for like rims or
a spoiler
yeah but like you know you get like you
know a carbon fiber spoiler and that's
like 300 bucks the comic was originally
like 50. so you flip the comic keep your
own which is the collection i got today
flip it for a car part sell it on ebay
double whatever so like you just liberty
flippity flies you ever feel bad about
giving somebody such a bad exchange also
what if the kid was me who was poor that
gave you my 50 cents at all i gave you
my spoiler my carbon fiber
yeah i gave you my goddamn muffler
but it started just 50 cents it was
never like a lot i just like made it
work that's true and i just like it
sounds like somewhere in there somebody
got scammed i tried not never cause like
i'm apologizing for whatever businesses
or whatever people that might have felt
wronged in me getting the money to move
all right
yes push that over to our capitalist
kingdom i don't even know i don't even
know what to do i don't know where to
pull from anymore
no i'm not worthy yeah and i mean all
you did was admit that you didn't even
say you stopped doing this
yeah you could just say that you do this
that's true is that not american
you could run for president
entrepreneurship
right
did we did we get a poll uh going from
here do we know did you just
so that he's he's my tutor um
i oh god this is so uncomfortable
they're all so uncomfortable uh i was a
very good tutor and i hate uh how could
a tutor work you'll find out uh and i
was really into the idea of like like
getting a kid and like blowing away what
they could have achieved by like
overdoing it a little bit and like
seeing like
my main thing was that would help kids
get into college and so i'd be like all
right we're gonna work on your sat score
we're going to work on your essays we're
going to work on all this stuff
and so i would prime myself in that and
there was this girl who had been
tutoring since she was like in like 10th
grade and 11th grade was like a big year
for getting to college and it's like
12th grade and they
she's like sending me emails a lot and
like just like and i'm going kind of
above and beyond this makes me look like
such a freaking creep i'm being called a
con artist
all i was doing was hustling
uh but all i'm trying to do is help this
this really nice nerdy girl get into
college uh but i do realize that like
i'm probably going like a little too too
hard on this and um
at a certain point i guess like they um
like the parents are a little concerned
that maybe like the daughter
is either developing feelings for me or
that there's like a relationship they're
like so they like they bring it to my
bosses and they're like hey we is
something going on here
right
this is not the movie parasite it
that's exactly my parasite i was living
in the basement yeah by the parents uh
uh with eric and his computer uh
demonic devices so they they directed it
to you they bring a piece of like
evidence uh and it's like she had gotten
like a a good score on a test or
something and i had written her a nice
note while she was like well she's
tutoring and she's they're like what did
he mean by this uh and at the bottom
it's me in my handwriting saying like uh
you're so amazing i'm so proud of you uh
i i just can't wait uh for you to to
blow us all
and so i have to know and so i have to
go it's a multi-page test turn it to the
back of the front page away
blow us all away philip your tutor
uh we had a very uncomfortable
conversation if this was during the time
hamilton came out then they wouldn't
have been asking that question exactly
that's what i said i said wait 10 years
it's gonna be a rap hit musical hip-hop
based on hamilton
minorities
i'm telling you it's gonna be a hit
it's very important i got
institutionalized for a little bit
yeah i mean as far as pregnant pauses go
that one takes well they because they
literally like they flip even if you
flip over the thing you wouldn't see you
had to turn back to the next page anyway
so go ahead and vote in the chat who you
think is clearly
i'm not even more worthy i'm not even
gonna try
uh we had a good run me and that girl
[Laughter]
benchmark yeah we uh got that two bills
oh
i get to swear um john do we have time
to do the next segment
next segment which is mine it's the
break room breakdown
also um who do i who do i swear at uh
rob r like here rob r give me a camera
too wait let me get out of the way of
this no no i want i want you oh no
dirty um look here raw bar you're a
piece of [ __ ] you're garbage trash
nothing can compare to you not even
philip you are healthy to me you are
nothing but a little simp boy and a
little [ __ ] boy i'm gonna like you sit
under the table on this spilled coke rug
that philip made a mess on and they
didn't know that they didn't know that
robert i hope you like being dumb
because that's all i'm gonna do
and there you go baby i got you
discussion number two so breaking
breakdown
moving on moving on
gave us an interesting scene where
members of the clandestines were
crystallized and turned to skeletons in
front of the mislike portal
boss has a theory that this could be a
form of terrorism missed go ahead and
play the clip baby
baby
go ahead and play clip baby boss is in
erin's boss
she turns into a statue of what this
episode's audio description refers to as
quote black crystalline rock which then
crumbles to reveal her skeleton and yes
this transformation does resemble the
way pterogenesis is shown in agents of
shield terrigen mist forms a rocky
cocoon around a person and then they
emerge from that cocoon as an inhuman
with powers maybe pterogenesis will be
revealed in the series as a worthiness
judgment in the nor realm as you pass
through the veil if your heart is impure
you emerge from that cocoon dead but if
your heart is pure like maybe if aisha
or kamala were to try to pass through
this veil they'd emerge from that cocoon
transformed
great oh
oh oh there we go okay we're back
sorry we're back uh rob r i just want to
redo it i love you thank you for pushing
us over the edge you guys if you watch
the other breakdowns all i do is curse
out one person in the chat um it's
normal it's what i do that's all i know
so
assuming this is true what does this
mean for cameron he didn't pass through
the mist his mom gave it to him but it
seems that power is regardless is it
possible that the clandestines were
experimenting on each other
i can't like not make everything like
yeah i'm starting right after the rob r
speech she gave earlier sure you put us
on certain zones well i think this would
this we talked about it yesterday that i
just think that this is a good tie along
if they want to in the future to be like
yes the x-men are here and they started
in
we talked about gerogenesis yesterday i
do think it's an option to plant the
seed without necessarily like
establishing it or not like i don't know
if episode six is going to say that was
terrigen miss but i think in a year or
two they can be like remember when we
showed you like they can make this an
open-ended thing inhumans are now canon
i think so but like well they are yeah
because we have black holes yeah but
like i don't think they have to write it
in pen i think they can keep it in
pencil like i think this is very
consciously them allowing cake and eat
it too like you'll have to invest yet
remind me did we ever see anybody uh
affected by a terrorist miss and not
survive it
in agents of shield we only saw people
come out as yeah is it a thing i'm not
that familiar with that in the comics is
it a thing in the comics everybody
survives kills the x-men it kills
mutants
basically that's what causes the the
battle right right and humans versus
x-men is because they're both trying to
save their own species yeah so that's
what they just did and watched my
quality awakened her powers yeah but
also it killed other people so maybe
it's like a similar thing of like maybe
those people have the mutant gene or
something that i mean if they bring that
in early then they could totally but
again they can plant that later they can
say like that's what that was that's why
those people died and why other people
got powers if they want to yeah and
that's what i think they'll do is like
they'll leave it for a future two years
from now like i don't think they're
gonna i personally don't think episodes
yeah two years from now when we're all
old but i don't think it'll be
i do think that was terrigen missed
personally but i don't think we'll know
for sure
i feel like i'm going to be mad if i'm
like it is not terrigen mist but then
again three years from now they're like
it is terrigen missed so that's why i'm
like you know i'm going to stick with my
guns and say that's not terrible to miss
right now okay i know damn well is
ontario miss in six years it might be
but not today they need somebody to go
through all of the mcu with like an
efficiency pass like this kind of looks
like this now they have anything
yeah they might have a rockstar show
that's a job
yeah i feel like they would have said
tarajin missed at some point so far in
miss marvel because like we got a lot of
new terms in dr strange multiverse
madness with the whole dream jumping
thing the body jumping over yeah it
reverses or whatever yeah so like they
can give us lots of lore yeah yeah so i
feel like we would have heard terrigen
mist or something at this up until this
point you know
i mean they've been on the fence about
it for so long because once you say it
it brings in the x-men so it's like now
that we have professor x shown in
multiverse madness i think they're like
no we can say more like but they never
said they were mutants no but i think
they're allowed to be like oh this is
adjacent like this is only and they do
own fox now so they could technically
start saying mutant i really like the
idea of waiting for mutants to be like
its own thing like i want mutants to be
as big or bigger than avengers ever was
because x-men are so like it's its own
corner marvel like x-men never needed to
blend with the rest of marvel it always
felt like its own thing and then
sometimes team up i'd like x-men to be
multiple tv shows i want origin movies i
want the team ups to feel like avengers
level events when they get to them but i
think right now we need the the culture
of pop culture to get out of avengers
mindset like i think you need young
avengers dark avengers thunderbolts
whatever they're going to call that team
so people are like okay now we don't
trust superheroes that leads to x-men
without it feeling like they just jumped
from x-men to avengers
if they do that in the in uh too abrupt
away it's kind of like oh we got the toy
we actually want to play with yeah so
instead you have to find a way to go
back and interweave in the whole thing
why do i think this phase four is doing
that it might be personal what if they
um
go back in the same way i was talking
about an efficiency pass there's people
that got powers from cosmic reasons
people that got powers from accidents
forever maybe a lot of the people we've
met over the course of the mcu so far
there's something they had in common
kind of like the terrigen missed an
option maybe there's a different one and
somebody starts to identify that and
this like kind of hate word starts
getting used like these mutants and so
it's like a word that it would it hasn't
been used not because those people
didn't exist but because there wasn't a
connecting point right people didn't
realize that gene because why would we
detect an x gene that we haven't we
weren't looking for whatever but it's
like oh and then the way they would do
that is identify a couple of characters
we already know for instance wanda right
like somewhere it's like oh it turns out
why do these people this way oh they
have this gene yeah and then this
disgusting mutant word and then we made
a familiar character a new character
then we made an x-men that we all want
to see but then it's like this like
almost like um secret invasion kind of
thing like all of these mutants have
been among us this whole time and it's
actually uh infiltrated our entire
population and it's like there's a
million of them and then it's a world
that hates and fears us which is the
point right you want it to feel like
unnerving you want the the in mcu
universe to be uncomfortable yeah and
then they don't have to have that weird
thing of the word mutants is kind of
like weird and also the word x-men now
is apparently they're like unsure what
to do with that yeah instead we can use
that as canonically as like
the word mutant is a identifier that
they choose to take back at some point
or whatever but like we don't have to
use that to because then it is going to
be weird of we had superheroes and
avengers and inhumans and now mutants
sort of it's just going to feel like
another thing if you want to be as big
as you're talking about you have to be a
big girl they can even make x-men a slur
like generation x oh you're next men
like that's something that like has a
negative connotation right oh you listen
to like nirvana in high school yeah okay
like some sort of like x-men like that
that could be a thing yeah okay
i'm sorry
there's dogs in the office they're going
to eat it and it's bad for dogs going
through our polls really quick do you
think the veils made a terror general we
got 57 said yes i can see the i can see
the veil i can see the veil that's fine
what are you most excited to see an echo
you guys think matt murdock slash
daredevil 85 which yes i agree who would
you rather see on the next as the next
on-screen spider-man tom hollander
andrew garfield you guys said andrew
tom holland tom allen you guys said tom
holland he's not far behind though
garfield i'm just saying you want to see
andy again see that no one voted toby
mcguire
who's the most worthy jessica with 36
percent uh followed by twelve and
phillip in this eric i think they were
just disgusted by you
you know it's a disgusting time in my
life
i love that you were like the computer
was not sticky like you like the thing
you felt like you had to say that's at
least hygienic
uh we'll do a quick really speed round
of these super chats because i want to
give them to you regardless uh ishmael
mckinney says cameron is going to
sacrifice himself and his death will
spread the nor which will be the
terrigen mist ooh love that i like that
a lot perfectly jake
jacob
8 9
thank you for giving me something to
watch before i go see through four in an
hour y'all are the best oh nice
enjoy
don't love marvel duncan's block me
marble wiggins are so good i just love
reading happy people on the internet
yeah
the christy says someone was watching a
new rockstars video while i was in the
theater for love and thunder earlier
today if he says if he sees this says hi
oh see this hi coincidentally i was
wearing my moon night late it's
obsession tonight all right to represent
said just bring kilgrave back somehow i
love it
creepy as hell but i
um i re-watched it and i was like oh i
don't know i think it really was hard
bring kilgray back the first villain
that professor x has to deal with or
something like
that
we got charlie 836 jess i'm still
waiting on my arcane 2 cup
me too baby you can make it too baby no
one's stopping me you guys are stopping
me what do you mean no one's stopping no
one's asked me make it i've been trying
to make the umbrella
we're done make that too yeah people
forget they can ask me things
make it desperately disagree uh i want
to take this next one someone was
watching a new watcher no no not that
one where did it go somebody said that
uh freight girl said that we should hire
koi because they're having a such a
great time with him on the break room
let's go ahead and get into this so how
much would it cost us for you to work
here let's make sure everyone so that's
the conversation
do you i'll be so messed up get hired
before me i'll go off
or thunderbolts first by fray girl
oh uh i think we personally will see uh
young avengers first and then i think
the the villain will have to fight his
thunderbolts so i think we'll get we've
already assembled more young avengers
but i think they'll be like oh these
kids are blah blah but these adult
heroes are just trying to like help them
and then all of a sudden the adults are
suddenly bad guys i was about to ask a
question then i answered in my own head
i was going to say what are they going
to do with thadius ross not of the past
and it's like oh that's going to be the
story right daddy stross was assembling
a team and then it's he was doing a nick
fury move of making avengers but he was
so the name of the thunderbolts in his
honor exactly and then we feel like this
noble patriotism of this fine general
trying to make his own avengers
thunderbolts and then they betray the
young avengers so the answer is kind of
both simultaneously but i think we'll
see the event young avengers form first
personally the young avengers are
already formed also frey girl tbd we'll
let you know those quarters get shifted
around
perfect you guys that was the break room
thank you for just delightful today you
guys were fun we said a lot of stuff
about our past that i hope you guys
don't hold over
a lot more putts this week most of them
involved yeah yeah a lot of butts a lot
of butts and a lot of butts in seats for
thor 11 thunder go and see it because
this weekend we have a lot of breakdowns
coming your way from eric voss and mt we
also have the boys underground that's
premiering tomorrow because today's the
finale and if you don't keep up with it
5 p.m pacific uh pacific time is usually
when they drop it so you got like an
hour to start if you want to start ahead
of time um make sure you like subscribe
hit that notification bell share with
notification bell share with your
friends and give us all love on twitter
and never be mean to us
stay tuned for the arcane breakdown the
umbrella academy video
enjoy love and thunder tweet at all of
us i want to hear what you guys thought
i love marvel weekends i love fans
getting experiences together i love
watching those videos about just rivalry
the world's been dark enjoy some love
and thunder eric give us the final word
someone said you guys should do an arm
wrestle we'll do a net tomorrow we'll do
it tomorrow we should arm tomorrow
goodbye
he's signing us off
uh
keep having fun and being freaky hell
yeah weirdo yeah